hello i would like to thank the
organizers of the napb meeting and this
session for the opportunity to share a
few highlights of our research and
field-based either put phenotyping over
the past 10 years and convey our future
research directions
the path from genotype to terminal
phenotype
such as yield covers a large range of
spatial and temporal scales
the diverse set of processes operating
at and across the intervening scales can
have subtle effects on the terminal
phenotype
however they also govern a large set of
endophenotypes
or intermediate phenotypes including
properties like protein and metabolite
levels
or physiological and morphological
attributes of the plant that can be
modeled
furthermore interactions between
processes within and across scales
can lead to emergent behavior
my talk today will focus on how we are
merging the fields of plant biology
and robotics
to collect early season intermediate
phenotypes or into phenotypes for
building models that are highly
predicted of terminal phenotypes
at the end of season
radical collaborations were essential to
advancing dna sequencing technology
to where it now costs about a hundred
dollars to resequence a human genome
this has resulted in a deluge of
low-cost genomics data
in contrast phenotyping is a 10 000 year
old challenge that started with the
visual assessment of plants for
desirable attributes at the time of
plant domestication
phenomics technologies have only just
begun to evolve more rapidly
and phenomics data are typically more
expensive to collect than genomics data
on a large scale
this has caused the massive imbalance in
the volume of data collected
radical collaborations among plant
biologists
engineers and computer scientists are
needed to bring the lab to the field
allowing multi-scale data to be
collected
the concept of field-based
high-throughput phenotyping
fbhtp
has been advocated by those of us in the
plant-breeding community
to reduce human effort
collect higher amounts of data
evaluate large population sizes at many
time points in a growing season
decrease subjectivity when scoring
plants
and diminish phenotyping costs over time
on the left is an example of a more
classical physiological phenotyping
approach
with an instrument that collects highly
detailed data but does not scale well to
large plant populations
on the right is an example of a
phenotyping system with greater
throughput for non-contact simultaneous
measurements of multiple canopy
phenotypes in the field environment
stimulated by the need for better
phenotyping in the field i started
collaborating in 2010 with agricultural
engineers at the university of arizona
while i was a research geneticist
working for the usda ars in maricopa
arizona
our design field-based high-speed
phenotyping system
shown in this icon
was used to study the genetic basis of
physiological traits and their
relationship to lint yield in a cotton
recombinant inbred lawn population
the field based high put throughput
phenotyping system
could scan our field trial of nearly 500
plots in less than one hour
furthermore we use this rapid
phenotyping platform to monitor changes
in three physiological phenotypes and
multiple time points within a day
and multiple days across the growing
season
and these three canopy traits
were temperature normalized difference
vegetation index or ndvi and height
with canopy temperature as an example
these data were used to map qtl
expression patterns across
cotton plant development
as an intermediate phenotype
these canopy temperature data were also
found to have a moderately strong
correlation with lint yield at peak
flowering
despite this progress
i was still driven by the need to better
dissect
the components of lint yield
in collaboration with andy french and
allison thompson at usdars maricopa
arizona we demonstrated the potential of
light detection and ranging or lidar
sometimes called laser scanning for
phenotyping defoliated cotton plants
the field based high throughput
phenotyping system fit it with a lidar
unit
scanned the entire field
allowing us to extract lidar data
on a per plot basis
and a per plant basis
in this point cloud visualization of a
single extracted cotton plant
a euclidean clustering approach was used
to count the number of cotton bowls with
reasonable accuracy
this was an initial indication to us
that optical phenotyping could be used
to better understand yield components
ground vehicles and lidar units have
evolved since our early work in cotton
in a collaboration with ed buckler led
by joe gage a postdoc in his lab the
tara cinch's sub-canopy rover from
earthsense fitted with a lidar unit
was used to characterize the whole plant
architecture of maize plants in the
field
joe used the computational workflow to
compress
the 3d lidar point cloud data into 2d
density maps
which were then analyzed with two
dimensionality reduction techniques
principle component analysis and an auto
encoder
the extracted latent space phenotypes
lsps
were used to predict manually measured
phenotypes by partial least squares
regression
the lsps contained enough plant
architecture information
to predict
architectural and non-architectural
traits
joe is continuing this work to map
g by time and growth curve parameters in
maze hybrids that are part of the
genomes to fields initiative
we now shift our attention from the
ground to the sky
in the past few years we have assessed
the potential use of unoccupied aerial
vehicles uavs
as efficient co-workers for precisely
monitoring the incidence
and severity of northern leaf blight a
maze foliar pathogen
the aerial system that we used at the
time consisted as shown here of a dji
matrice 600 and a sony alpha a6000
camera with a zoom lens
the large size nlb lesions as seen in
the image on the right
makes the disease an attractive
candidate
for image-based phenotyping
in a collaborative study involving hod
lipson and his research group at
columbia university and rebecca nelson
in her research group at cornell
university
harvey wu an undergraduate student in
hod's lab use a convolutional neural
network or cnn model pre-trained on
imagenet
to transfer learn rather than training
from scratch
for a presence absence detection of nlb
lesions
the cnn model created interpretable heat
maps as shown here on the right
of the original images
showing the locations of putative
lesions
the cnn model achieved 95 percent
accuracy on a separate test test and
resolution was achieved at the sub-leaf
scale
beyond incidence
breeders and pathologists want to
measure disease severity
which is a quantitative attribute
thus we attempted to estimate the number
size and location of nlb lesions
ethan stewart a former postdoc in my lab
trained a mascar cnn model
to segment nlb disease lesions in uav
images
this deep learning model approach for
instance segmentation accurately
detected
and segmented individual lesions in a
holdout test set
the mean intersect over union iou
between the ground truth and predicted
lesions was 0.73
with an average precision of 0.96
at an intersection over union threshold
of 0.50
in these images shown here the ground
truth is marked with white polygons
and predicted lesion instances marked in
magenta
allowing you to visualize the high
degree of intersection
one note
is that due to variation in plan height
and image resizing during data set
preparation the scale here is variable
between images and provided for general
guidance only
i would like to now highlight our
efforts in wheat and cassava
first in wheat
in a collaboration with simmet a former
phd student co-advised by mark sorel's
and me margaret kraus
demonstrated the use of hyperspectral
reflectance derived relationship
matrices
for the prediction of grain yield in
cement wheat in mexico
the aerial hyperspectral phenotyping
approach can monitor physiological
changes resulting from plant growth
stage and the environment
therefore hyperspectral
reflectance-derived relationship
matrices can capture both genetic
manifest and
genotype by environment interactions
this contrasts with pedigree and genomic
relationship matrices
which are static
shown in this figure are the single
environment prediction accuracies of
wheat yield
across four site years two environments
and two breeding cycles with g as the
genomic relationship matrix
the a matrix derived from pedigree
and h as the hyperspectral derived
relationship matrices
when considering the growth stage at the
time of phenotyping
prediction accuracies were highest at
the heading and grain fill stages
overall
the hyperspectral base accuracies are
similar to
or slightly higher than
genomic and pedigree based
relationship matrices
i encourage you all to look at the
results of multi-environmental
prediction and correcting for days to
heading in margaret's g3 paper that was
published in
2019
in our lab we have also worked on the
use of low-cost
handheld spectrometers for phenotyping
quality traits and planned breeding
programs jenna hershberger a recent phd
graduate from our lab
led a collaboration with iita in nigeria
to predict cassava root dry matter with
the handheld scio spectrometer shown
here on the left jenna found cassava
root dry matter content to be highly
predictable within 10 field trials
as shown in the figure on the right
mean partial least squares regression
model performance range from an rs
square of 0.62 to 0.89
for within trial predictions
which is within the range typically
achieved with laboratory grade
spectrometers
a pre-print of bioarchive is available
on jenna's work if you would like to
learn more
in general technology has largely
limited us to phenotyping macro-scale
traits
and indirectly measuring those traits at
best
working with piers gian
a phd student in abe strokes lab at
cornell university
in washington liu a former postdoc in my
lab and others at cornell
we developed swelling shrinking
nanoparticles with fluorescent reporters
to rapidly detect water status inside a
plant
aquadus as we call it shrinks with
decreasing water potential and hence
there is increased interaction between
two fluorophores we measure this
interaction in terms of fret efficiency
aqua dust which resides within the
apoplastic region
allows for in-situ minimally invasive
measurements of water status as water
potential in local physiologically
relevant micro environments of leaves
using an external sensor
this work represents a major step
towards high throughput phenotyping of
water potential
ultimately we can couple water potential
variation with biological and physical
processes
to accelerate our understanding of the
factors
that are critical for improving drought
tolerance and crops
this work was recently published in
panas this year
what is the next step for the use of
aerial and ground systems in planned
phenotyping
through two recently funded nsf
proposals we are collaborating with
plant biologists
engineers and modelers at cornell
to collect phenotypic data with robots
operating at the canopy understory and
below ground levels
rob shepard's robotics group will lead
the development of a one to two foot
worm-like robot
that emulates how a board drills into
the ground
combined with a wave-like motion that
copies how worms move through soil
by quantifying root features soil
properties
metabolites and water that includes the
use of aqua dust we hope to use
predictive models to combine the
multi-scale below
and above ground characteristics as
intermediate features
to predict such traits as grain yield
and stress tolerance
agriculture in the 20th century has
relied on chemistry and qualitative
patterns
i think that agriculture in the 21st
century will be the century of robotics
and pinpointing the causal factors
driving those correlative patterns
it will then better allow us to model
what we know and if needed predict what
we don't know
our multi-institution group of
collaborators comprising the proposed
center for research on programmable
plants crops
is led by susan mccooch at cornell
university
notably crops grew out of the cornell
institute for digital agriculture ceda
within the crops project we share a
vision of developing programmable plants
with genome-encoded gene switches
sensors and reporters with digital
readouts
serving as endophenotypes that can be
read into software and acted upon by
robots
we collectively call this the internet
of living things
how could we begin harnessing the
genetic power of programmable plant
populations
in one example the crops internet of
living things could be used to perform
intensive multi-scale measurements of
endo phenotypes across a training
population
of genetically diverse programmable
plants
this will serve as the genetic framework
for the use of genomic prediction models
to predict endo phenotypes such as
protein abundance in developing plant
tissues for hundreds to thousands of
untested genotypes
it will further allow us to predict the
function and activity of gene circuits
and untested genetic
backgrounds would like to thank all
those that have contributed to this work
and the funding agencies that have
provided support
especially columbia university
university illinois urbana champaign
earth sense university of arizona
nextgen cassava usa lark
and all of our collaborators at cornell
university
i'm happy to take your questions at this
time thank you very much for listening